Okay, welcome everyone to the DDPS
webinar series.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
First of all, please mute yourself
during the talk unless you have
questions. If you have questions, you're
welcome to unmute and ask. Otherwise,
please you use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end.
Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed, so
please watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. That's about it.
Now, let me introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Greg
Beroza, who is the Wayne Loel Professor
of Earth, Energy, and Environmental
Sciences in the Department of
Geophysics at Stanford University.
His research concerns earthquake science
broadly with a focus on developing
techniques for analyzing seismograms to
understand how earthquakes work and to
quantify the hazards they pose.
Since 2007, he has been first deputy
director,
then co-director of the Southern
California Earthquake Center.
Since 2013, he has also been co-director
of the Stanford Center for induced and
triggered seismicity.
His current research includes using
ambient field measurements for ground
motion prediction, developing data
mining and machine learning methods for
earthquake detection and
characterization,
and understanding the systematics of
induced slow and intermediate depth
earthquakes.
He has authored over 200 peered reviewed
scientific journal articles.
Um
Dr. Berza was an NSF presidential young
investigator, has been fellow of the AGU
since 2008 and recipient of many other
numerous uh the awards. Today,
Greg will talk about towards
complete machine learning based uh
earthquake monitoring workflows. Uh
please enjoy his wonderful talk. Now,
without further ado, let me pass the
baton to Greg by asking one random
question as usual.
Today's random question is, what is your
favorite things to do other than
research?
Other than research, uh my favorite
thing to do is probably play guitar.
Oh, nice. You like music. I love music,
too.
I love music, yeah.
Wonderful, wonderful.
Okay. Well, thank you, Young Young Soo,
for that very generous introduction, and
and thank you to the audience
for uh uh
attending the the talk. So, as Young Soo
said, I'm going to be talking about work
in seismology, which is what I do, uh
using methods of AI,
almost entirely uh
neural networks of one sort or another
for improving earthquake monitoring. And
And you see at the bottom of this first
slide a long list of
a lot of symbols of different
organizations that have funded this work
at at different points uh in time. So, I
want to make sure to give credit to
them.
So,
I gather this is a some somewhat of a
broad audience, so I'd like to first
make the case for why earthquakes are an
interesting
target from a data science point of
view. So, one one thing that makes them
interesting is that we have a lot of
data. So, we don't know when earthquakes
are going to happen ahead of time,
unfortunately.
Um so, we have to be measuring the
motion of the ground all the time in
order to detect them. So, that's we
typically sample at 100 samples per
second, and we do that 24 hours a day,
365 days a year. Our networks range from
isolated sensors of one to many tens of
thousands of sensors. We have very many
small earthquakes, as we'll see, they
follow a power law, such that for each
magnitude unit increase, we get 10 times
more earthquakes.
Our data has been digital since 1990,
and we've saved all of it since about
2000. So, there's a a lot of data to to
sift through.
The signals are interesting. They're
broadband. They're um they have certain
characteristic attributes. Adjacent
events that occurred near one another
have similar waveforms, and that's
that's actually very important for what
I'm going to be talking about today.
Uh
Our noise is also interesting. So, we
have noise all the time. It has all
sorts of sources uh from cultural, that
is people moving around or driving
around,
to uh the oceans, the atmosphere. All
these things couple into the earth and
and make our readings noisy. It's
non-stationary. Most of what we record
is noise, actually, and we can use it
for uh
for um certain purposes.
Earthquakes themselves are not
completely understood, so there's a
scientific frontier
uh that makes them interesting. They
tell us about processes that occur deep
in the earth and are otherwise
inaccessible. So, seismology is you can
think of it as a sort of form of remote
sensing. And then, of course, uh
earthquakes are threatening. They're
they're they cause great damage and
uh loss of life when when they occur, if
they occur in the wrong places. So, it's
important to understand them as as best
we can.
So, an example of a destructive
earthquake sequence
that occurred over the past decade plus
is in Central Italy. The Apennines of
Italy are slowly spreading apart. And
that manifests as occasional
earthquakes.
And in 2016-2017,
there was a series of earthquakes, the
magnitude 6 Amatrice earthquake that
killed over 300 people
followed by other damaging earthquakes
including one near
Norcia.
And this this earthquake sequence
happened over a period of over 10 years.
And uh
we that that sort of behavior where you
have not just one earthquake but a
sequence of earthquakes is
characteristic of the Apennines. And so
here and everywhere else,
we'd like to understand earthquake
sequences better better. We'd like to be
able to forecast the the likelihood of
future events better than we can do
right now.
And so we're the premise of this
presentation is that we can use
uh
methods of AI to do this
earthquake monitoring better than we do.
And that that better monitoring will
give us a deeper understanding of
earthquake occurrence.
So, shown on the left is
a is is sort of the standard earthquake
catalog. It It It's It's focused on the
Amatrice main shock which is shown there
with a yellow star. Each one of these
red and blue dots represents a small
earthquake color coded by time over a
1-year period going from red
to blue.
And the topography of the Apennines is
shown in in the background. And this is
an inset is a zoom in on this overall
decade-long
decade plus long sequence. What's shown
on the right is
the catalog we were able to develop
using the methods of mostly deep
learning. It has a magnitude of
completeness where we record all the
earthquakes down to about magnitude 0.5.
And because there's so many small
earthquakes relative to large
earthquakes, the information density
goes up by an order of magnitude.
There's 11
No, I think that is 13 times more
earthquakes on the figure on the right
as compared to the left.
And so we
were able to generate these catalogs
using exactly the same data, but just
treating it
a little more
carefully, if you like.
And so what I'm going to explain or try
to explain during this talk is how how
we develop these better catalogs. I'll
call them deep catalogs for sort of a
shorthand. And and and then towards the
end I'll show some applications that
demonstrate the sort of things we can
learn from these deep catalogs.
Our data are seismograms, so that's
they're digital recordings of the motion
of the ground. Typically, we measure
velocity, not always, but typically.
Ideally, we measure the the full vector,
so the three components of velocity. I
already mentioned that it's continuous
and our our
sensors
are arrayed in networks of up to tens of
thousands of
instruments.
Um
one nice thing for machine learning
for
for supervised machine learning, for
example, is that we have already
existing earthquake catalogs that have
very large
labeled data sets. They're in
almost ready to go
that can be used for
for training
deep neural networks, but these catalogs
have issues. So, I'll just illustrate a
few of these issues. Sometimes we have a
set of waveforms. So, this is a
seismogram here. This is time increasing
from left to right. This is 6 seconds of
record. It's 100 samples per uh
or 1,000 samples per second on this
scale.
And uh this is the motion uh of the
ground in in digital counts. So, here's
an example where we have
the catalog says there's an earthquake,
but there actually isn't anything in the
waveforms. So, that those sort of
blunders creep into catalogs.
A more common thing really is it here we
have a an earthquake. So, there's a very
impulsive P-wave followed by an S-wave.
That's sort of the characteristic
signature of local earthquakes.
But there's a smaller earthquake back
here later in the record. And it's And
there are a lot of these smaller
earthquakes because of the power law
behavior, these are the the events that
are missing from the catalog that we'd
like to find.
So, having this, you know, if we were to
consider this to be noise, that would be
exactly wrong.
Because those are the things we're
looking for. So, we have to be careful
with
of of having say missing labels in in
this instance.
And
during uh earthquake sequences like the
one I showed, there might be a lot of
these uh
earthquakes. So, here's here's what a
single earthquake that's um
in the catalog shown with blue, but
there are, you know, maybe a dozen or
more earthquakes
uh following it that are are not present
in the catalog. And we
we absolutely would not want to treat
that
as noise.
And then sometimes there there just
errors in the catalog. So, here's an
example where the onset of the
earthquake is supposed to happen uh at
the blue. That's what the catalog says,
and yet the the real beginning of it is
is a second or so
earlier.
So, uh Mostafa Mousavi, who was a a
postdoc and a
research scientist now at uh research
professor at Stanford, also at Google,
put together a a large global data set
of seismic signals
for
uh for AI.
It was and it was based on earthquake
catalogs, but it was uh but he did a
whole lot of quality control, added many
labels, put it in a data science
friendly uh format together with some
intro- some uh sort of introductory
seismology
such that it could be used by data
science practitioners who weren't
seismologists uh but who might be
interested in in seismology. So, that's
uh out there. This is published in um
IEEE Access if if anybody's interested
in exploring earthquake uh signals. We'd
love to We'd love to have you involved.
Okay, so what's the earthquake
monitoring task? Well, we're we're
listening, right? We're listening to the
with our sensors to the motion of the
ground.
And uh
so here's an example where we have six
stations. They're shown in in Matthew
here schematically with the black
triangles. We have two earthquake
sources, one shown in blue, one shown in
yellow.
And these are the waves that we record.
Now, when we record these waves, we
don't know where the earthquakes are.
Uh we don't even know how many
earthquakes there there are. So, our job
is to figure out from these wiggles
where the seismic waves are and how
where or what how many events are uh
are uh causing them. And when we do
that, then, you know, we could color in
the the blue seismograms for the blue
events uh the blue event and the yellow
seismograms for the yellow event, but we
don't know that a priori. That's
something we have to figure out. That
process
is called association because we're
associating
measured uh wave arrivals with the
events that caused them. And it's
central It's really central to this
problem.
So, how how is this done? Well, the
standard approach
uses
is is called STA/LTA or there there
other characteristic function based
methods, but basically they're they're
something similar to this where you take
a short-term running average of the
squared signal. So, here's our
seismogram. Here's the squared signal.
You take the ratio of a short-term and a
long-term running average. When you have
an impulsive arrival,
that statistic gets large and if it's
above a threshold, then we we say, "Hey,
there's a there's a wave arriving at the
station. We have to figure out what kind
of wave it might be or or maybe it's
it's not a it's not really a wave. Maybe
it's a
you know, some local noise source." But
that's that's sort of the fundamental
first step. Then we do that association
that I talked about and if it's it's a
real event, then we try to locate,
figure out where it is with
a form of triangulation based on the
wave equation
and then characterize it. So, calculate
it's it's say it's magnitude.
So, that's that sort of seems like an
easy task, a straightforward task, but
it's it's more like a lot of things,
it's more difficult than it looks. So,
here's here's an example. These are
seismograms. Each one of these is 10
minutes long now. And so, these are
offset. Each of these lines is offset by
10 minutes. Here's a nice earthquake.
You can see it has a very impulsive
first arrival. So, that STA/LTA
statistic will be large
and it, you know, will clearly register
that event. But on this same record,
there there are a bunch of small events
just like before. We'd like to capture
those, too, but they may not be strong
enough to to trigger our
sort of naive approach to
to measuring the arrival time of seismic
waves.
We also have cases where the where the
the earthquakes or events as we call
them, emerge from the the noise such
that the the LTA is large enough that
the STA the short-term average doesn't
pick up enough for them to be detected.
And these are important cases. And then,
perhaps even more important, is when we
have when the earth is really active,
when we have an earthquake swarm or a
volcanic eruption or an aftershock
sequence, the events are are closely
spaced in time such that the the
waveforms overlap such as shown here.
This is an earthquake swarm in New
Zealand.
And so, information is pouring out of
the earth,
but our our standard approach for
processing these data, uh you know,
doesn't perform very well. So, that
these are some of the challenges that we
we face. There are other challenges
related to noise, but but these are
there. These are enough.
Uh so, what I you know, what I promised
to talk about was a a
a workflow for earthquake monitoring.
And uh that's shown sort of
schematically here. I'll show variations
of this a number of times, but here's
our
seismograms recorded over many stations
in a network. That's our input. We have
steps of pre-processing. That's cleaning
up the data, maybe filtering it, getting
rid of bad traces. We pick the seismic
waves, detect the events. Those are sort
of related um
uh
tasks. We associate the phases to uh
events.
And then, once we do that, we try to
locate and and calculate the magnitude
and and other uh
parameters of the earthquake. And our
output,
we do this many, many times. And so,
over time, we we get a uh what's shown
here in sort of schematically a a
catalog of discrete uh seismic events.
Now, that the The way of doing this is
that these are done in serial.
So, one after the other and each time we
do that, there's the potential for
information loss and that information
loss
is is both in terms of the context, as
I'll talk about, and also uh the the
thresholding. So, we'll we'll return to
that and show a possible workarounds
that can help uh to avoid that.
Okay, so the first thing I'm going to
talk about just really quickly is
pre-processing and that's uh
and and that will be um using a a a very
deep convolutional neural network that
that we set uh to the task of
differentiating between the signal and
the noise.
And so, you you can see it has has many
many layers. We work in the time
frequency
uh
domain.
And uh it it has this standard uh
encoder-decoder structure.
And the the idea is that we we develop a
a mask of real numbers that um
that in time frequency space passes
either the signal or its complement, the
noise.
This is, you know, there there many
uh parameters to determine here, so we
need a lot, you know, it's data hungry,
we need a lot of uh examples and we
develop these examples by recombining
signal, known signal, with known noise
at varying signal-to-noise ratios such
that we have on the order of a billion
examples uh for the training data.
And so, that's enough
to despite the fact that this is very
deep, that's enough to to get a a model
that's uh quite effective.
So, here's here's our our simplistic
notion of a seismogram we have. This is
what we record, Y as a function of time
and frequency. We have some signal, we
have some noise, and we want to separate
the two. And so, what what that might
look like on a single trace is this. We
have
this noisy uh
long period signal, some high frequency
too, and then we have this earthquake
here. So we take the the the Fourier
transform of it and um
in these examples where we So we have
you know close to a billion examples
where we know the right answer. So on
the other side we have the
the uh
um you know the answer in our uh
our loss function and we we train it to
learn
these two things here in these two masks
in in time frequency space such that
when this is applied to the complex
spectrum it it passes the signal and
this passes the noise. Then then we just
inverse transform in order to get that
back. That's the idea. Of course it
depends, you know, it it works
it works up to a point but it ultimately
it will get defeated by noise if the the
noise is too strong.
And so this is sort of if you're
familiar with Wiener filtering, this is
sort of like that but but not quite. But
it's the the same the same sort of uh
idea.
Okay. So here here here are examples of
it. So of its application once trained.
And so this is using it on independent
test data. Here's our clean signal and
I'll show a zoom in on the the part of
the signal we care the most about which
is the initial part of the signal.
Here's our noise. And this is real
noise. This isn't Gaussian band limited
white noise or anything. This is, you
know, this is how the ground moved as
detected by a real
um seismometer.
Here's the sum of those two. So this is
a noisy signal where where we have been
in control of of what the SNR is cuz we
multiply this by some number and we add
it to that.
Um and then we we ask the the
pre-trained neural network to recover
the uh signal and the noise. And so,
this is what it comes up with.
And if you look closely, you can Well,
first of all, let's let's look here at
at the uh at the initial parts of it.
You can see it does a nice job of
recovering the shape of the signal.
There's very little pre-event noise.
If you look closely at the noise level
here, the recovered noise relative to
the true noise, you see there is some
diminution or lower lower amplitude
here.
So, there's crosstalk between the signal
and the noise,
but it it it it outperforms other
denoising methods that that are
available for um
for seismology. This is looking in the
time frequency uh space. And here again,
you can see the recovered It's actually
easiest to see in the recovered noise.
You can see that the the the noise is
not perfectly recovered. There's a sort
of a dark area here where it's it's
being attributed uh
to the signal. But for the most part,
we're we're able to recover the time
frequency behavior of the signal as it
was in the initial um
in in what's what's ground truth.
So, here's uh here's just another uh
example
where um this is the the noisy signal.
Here's what we recover from it. It's
very close to the original
signal, particularly the things we care
about, which is the initial care most
about, which is the initial shape.
Here's uh
uh uh you know, just another example. I
could show these all day. Here here we
try to trick it by not giving it any
signal at all and just giving it a bunch
of noise. And it's smart enough, it's
seen enough
noisy data to uh to know that this and
enough signals to know that this is not
signal, that this is all noise. So, the
recovered signal is it's basically It's
not quite, but it's basically flatlined.
So, we the So, we call this deep
denoiser for obvious reasons. and it and
it does a really nice job of cleaning up
our time series. Um and if we apply the
STA/LTA statistic for example to to try
and pick the arrival time of this this
wave, it basically fails
uh on the noisy data but once it's
cleaned up it it it works like a champ.
So this pre-processing
can um can make uh really a big
difference
um and help avoid false detections which
can be a real problem as shown here for
these uh simple methods.
And this just shows kind of a weird plot
but it shows
the recovered signal-to-noise ratio
versus the initial signal-to-noise
ratio. You want it to be high and deep
denoiser is the is the red crosses and
it it outperforms uh these these other
uh
other methods for removing for
separating signal from noise that are
available in
uh in seismology.
Okay, so that's the pre-processing part
of it. Now I'm going to talk about phase
picking.
And so this as uh as was deep denoiser
was Weichang Zhu was the student who who
worked on on this. He's now moved on.
He's a post-doc at Caltech.
But uh what we did here was to to
classify
use the the seismic signals that instead
of doing uh STA/LTA
we uh treated this as a classification
problem where we where where we
determined whether it was a P wave or an
S wave or noise.
And so here here's the data. The P wave
is the first arrival. S wave comes in
second. It's expressed most strongly on
these horizontal components. This is
east-west, north-south. And we just uh
trained it such that it would it would
recover a uh truncated Gaussian
distribution
so centered on the P wave or the S wave
arrival time depending on the wave type.
So, we're sort of
classifying the wave type, but we're
also sort of tricking this classifier
into measuring
an arrival time. And so, uh
it it it works uh extremely well. It
gets in in a in a and it generalizes
well. Uh we trained it only on data from
Northern California, but we've used it
all around the world and others have
too, and it measures the arrival time of
seismic waves to within few hundreds of
a second.
So, this just shows the output on this
independent
uh data
that was not used in the training. You
can see that it
very strongly on the on the P and the S
wave appropriately as it should. That's
a nice clean seismogram.
Here's a seismogram that's that's
clipped. So, the the
the actually it's the telemetry system
in this case
uh no longer faithfully transmit the
ground motion, but it's seen enough
examples of that. It knows how to pick
the P and S wave arrival times. And
likewise with noisy data, even if we
don't run deep denoiser, it can do quite
a good job of recovering
those uh
uh the the P and S wave arrival times.
Here it it's compared with a a sort of
standard method. So, the standard
standard method is this AR picker.
Uh and this is compared with the closest
thing we have to ground truth, which are
picked by expert analysts. And so, what
we'd like is a distribution that's
narrow and that's centered on zero cuz
that would mean that our uh automated
method is reproducing what the expert
seismologists do.
So, PhaseNet does quite well for the uh
for the P wave. This is this is two
tenths of a second here. You can see the
tails are almost nonexistent out there.
so it's it's doing extremely well.
Um AR picker does pretty well. It's a
little It's skewed a little bit late to
late arrivals. You can see there's more
energy in the tails here, but it does
pretty well on on the P wave. The P wave
is the first arrival, so it's easier to
pick. The S wave is is not the first
arrival, so it's harder to pick because
there are other scattered waves that are
interfering with it. But uh PhaseNet
does quite well with the S waves as
well. This is, you know, maybe the
energy's
This is also plus or minus 2/10 of a
second. So, that's
uh there's more energy in the tails.
Obviously, there's more dispersion about
the mean, but the mean again is centered
right around zero.
And comparing that with the
the uh the sort of existing uh method
for S picks, you can see the
distribution here is really fat. It's
really skewed. Uh this information is
really not uh super useful. So, uh deep
learning in this case really
dramatically outperformed other methods
that don't have the ability to learn um
in in picking the arrival time of
seismic waves.
So, that's that's really important cuz
it's foundational to the steps that
follow. The very next step is a step
called association where we figure out
how many earthquakes there they are and
which waves are associated with each
earthquake.
So, association is is figuring out with
what color each of these phases should
be if you if you like. Um and question
is why is it difficult to do
association? We don't know a priori the
number of earthquakes. Events that are
close in time, like that swarm in New
Zealand, overlap. And so the the arrival
times are sort of tangled up with each
other.
Little earthquakes, and there are a lot
of little earthquakes. Those little
earthquakes are only recorded on a few
station and the the recording network
changes with time which you know
complicates everything.
Um in addition the background noise is
non-stationary.
We don't know the wave type a priori but
with something like PhaseNet we do
because we've trained it to pick the the
P and S waves. So this is something we
can fix.
We have uh both true and false picks due
to to noise. That's something we can
control.
And this sequential application of
picking and then locating or associating
and locating leads information loss
which we can also
uh deal with at at some computational
cost.
So we came up with a a new approach to
doing this using a Gaussian mixture
model so it it it treats these uh
phases, phase arrival times as
distributions
and goes through an iterative soft
clustering uh unsupervised clustering
method to try to figure out how many
events there are and which phases belong
to what uh what events. And of course
this is it iterative um
and but it it converges quite quickly.
It has some advantages over uh this
process has some advantages over
standard association algorithms. We
built into it the ability to pick or the
ability to use both P and S waves.
So that's something we don't have to
solve for. That's very helpful. And we
we use some amplitude information as
well which allows you know allows
further resolution of ambiguity when
there are multiple uh events.
Okay, so just an example during a very
intense earthquake sequence. This is the
Ridgecrest, California aftershock
sequence. This is uh
what 300 seconds of record. What's shown
here each each one of these
small circles represents a seismic phase
measurement. And the uh uh pluses
represent
uh events that we've been able to
associate compared with few other uh
studies of this earthquake sequence. The
Southern California Seismic Network, the
center catalog has three events during
this time. We have about 10 times as
many. We have about 50% more again than
Ross et al. 2000 uh 19. That's not
necessarily better because it's possible
to have false uh
false locations or false associations
here, too. The The point in showing this
is that we it it's very good at finding
multiple events that are closely spaced
uh
in time, which is something that we
wanted to be able to do.
Okay.
So, to this point, we've treated these
these each of these tasks individually
in a sort of modular way.
But, it's because these these tasks are
related, it's possible to combine
them. So, we developed a method that we
called earthquake transformer, we
published it a year and a half ago
that has uh
has a attention mechanism, has a
recurrent uh component to
to uh capture the sequencing of seismic
phases and has a convolutional component
to to capture the features of the
waveform.
And And what it does is is it doesn't
just uh pick the phases, but it also
detects the the event waveform that they
occur within. And that waveform context
is uh helpful. So, here's Here's the uh
Here's the what the network looks like.
Just like PhaseNet, it has three
components of data in. The pink are the
convolutional parts. This is the the
recurrent uh Or no, the yellow is the
recurrent part. And the the global and
and local attention mechanisms are here
for
in this case detecting the output is the
is the duration of the waveform as shown
here
and uh
phase and output similar to phase net a
P and an S wave uh arrival time within
that
that waveform. So, that context allows
us to estimate the arrival times a
little bit better than uh phase net does
at least in the test that we've uh
carried out.
Another kind of context is the context
of the network. So, up to this point
we've treated seismograms one at a time
or or three components at a time, but
one station at a time and we haven't uh
we haven't really exploited the fact
that
nearby instruments should also record
waves if if
if if what if another uh
that is nearby instruments should record
the same waves with perhaps some
time lag. So, this is shown
uh skip
here in what's called a record section.
This is the distance from the earthquake
and this is the the the this is time
and what you can see is that there's
there's a a set of wiggles that
increase the arrival time increases. We
call that move out
with uh distance from the event. Now, if
you were looking at an individual one of
these seismograms, you might be hard
pressed to say I think the P wave
is is arriving right about here. But if
you can see what's happening in the
nearby stations, you can do a much
better job.
So, that information is really useful
and that's what we um
that's what we'd like to be able to use
both to determine that where the P wave
is say and where the S wave is
sort of here and that there's an
earthquake here.
So, the methods I've shown so far, they
just detected the waves,
threshold that information, and then and
then try to figure it all out where the
events are.
Um but this uh thing we call EQNet,
which has multiple neural networks, uh
tries to sort of do all of that at once.
So, the idea is the input data is no
longer a single from a single station or
single sensor, but it's a a network or
an array of instruments that are
distributed across, say, Northern
California.
We have a feature extraction network
that acts on the array
rather than the individual seismograms.
And from that, we train uh a a a a set
of neural networks that pick the S-wave
and the P-wave, and then uh
and
sort of crudely localize the event in in
space
and uh
time.
And so, the that looks something like
this. This is a depiction of the feature
space.
Here's uh data. Here's the individual P
and S-wave picks. And here's our
localization in the origin time, which
we don't know ahead of time, and X and
Y, or if you like, latitude
and longitude. Now, once we have these
uh once we have things localized and we
determine how many events there are,
there there well uh
developed algorithms for getting very
precise locations from them. But getting
to that stage is is sort of the key.
Okay. And we've applied this to the
Ridgecrest earthquake sequence, and it
it performs comparably well
to other deep learning-based
methods. I think ultimately, this method
or something like it is going to prevail
because it has the the I should I should
have mentioned when I was showing this,
um we we train all of this part of it
simultaneously.
So, these neural networks have all the
information to available them to them
all the time. We don't sort of threshold
and then and then move on.
Okay. So, I think ultimately a strategy
like that's going to prevail.
Now, there's a a lot of
processing involved here and
nearly all of it, actually all of what
I've uh talked to you about at this
point is embarrassingly parallel.
So, we've developed a a a workflow that
takes advantage of the of that. It's we
call it QuakeFlow. It's set up to run in
the the cloud. It's deployed in
Kubernetes, so it should be platform
independent. And it should take
advantage and have should have good
scaling uh
uh properties. And it it can be used in
sort of two modes. One one mode would be
to analyze very large archives of data
that that we have for
a order of a decade or two.
Uh that's looking backwards, but it's
also fast enough
that it can and it supports uh
streaming. Uh so, it can be used for
real-time or near real-time
processing with a minimal
um minimal latency.
And I my I should say that So, so all of
all of this part is embarrassingly
parallel. And then we have this add-on
here. This is a a precise
uh relative earthquake location method
that called HypoDD. It's it's For those
of you who are astronomers uh or
familiar with astronomy, it's it's
equivalent to adaptive optics, but
applied to um
seismology. So, that that's not
not embarrassingly parallel. So, that's
that's really uh tacked on to this. Um
But anyway, it it it it runs uh uh quite
quickly. So,
looking at uh 70 stations worth of data
uh for 3 years continuous
for Puerto Rico.
We we ran this with PhaseNet and with
the associator that I described on it
and it
it I was worried about the cost of the
cloud because I like most people I'm I'm
new to the cloud but it it only cost us
40 bucks. So that was quite reasonable
and we found seven times more
earthquakes close to 150,000 earthquakes
than were previously in the earthquake
catalog. So that's that's a real
that's a real
bargain. And we're we're able to see
much just like with Italy we're able to
see much more detail. So
this is from a
recently published study in
seismological research letters. We have
much many more earthquakes and much
better definition of the Guyaneau rift
which is this GR here and then the
Puento Montavo fault shown
shown there. So we
we get seven times more earthquakes and
we should be able to do much more
with them.
Same story for Hawaii. So we ran
QuakeFlow in Hawaii
just for the
six months recently. We get over a
factor of 10 more earthquakes than in
the standard catalog. So this is the
histogram of the number of earthquakes
with time.
Blue is what we find. Orange is what's
in the standard catalog. There are all
sorts of interesting things here. There
are deep events under the erupting uh
the actively erupting Kilauea caldera
deep events under Mauna Kea
shallow events along the
erupting rifts or recently erupting
rifts and then there's there's some
enigmatic deep events such as this one
which I'm not aware that anyone has seen
before.
Uh these are deep events. They're
color-coded by depth that stretch from
uh
from under uh Kilauea to the
to the northeast.
So, this is not during the most active
part of the eruption, but we we plan to
process the entire eruptive episode and
I you know, we're going to find millions
of earthquakes, I'm I'm certain and
we'll be able to get a better
uh understanding, I suspect, of how
they're related to eruptive
activity.
So, let me uh shift gears to some of the
things to describe some of the things
that we've learned from these deep uh
catalogs. So, this is uh work done by
current grad student Young Soo Park.
He's applied uh PhaseNet to
uh in multiple uh ways and in in this
case, he's looking at a little over a
year of of data.
He detected or he was able to locate
precisely almost 100,000 earthquakes. He
detected many several times that many,
but but we didn't have enough data to
uh to locate them
uh accurately.
But, what he was able to find was and
this is in central uh Arkansas, a a line
of events that defines the Guy
Greenbrier Fault. These are thought to
be related to uh deep disposal
wells and those wells are shown here
with the numbers two with the hexagons.
One, five, and two were the important
ones.
And then
excuse me, these colored uh seismicity,
those are due to hydraulic fracturing or
or or fracturing and
uh or fracking. And what um
what Young Soo was able to show was that
this this sequence on the main Guy
Greenbrier Fault, where most of these
earthquakes are, was actually two
sequences.
And
that the the wells involved in them is
thought to be uh
wells uh
Let's see here. Thought to be um
primarily wells one and five. Uh
probably well two was involved as well.
So So, what's shown here, this is a
cross-section of the plot going from
south to north.
Here are the three injecting
wells. The seismicity started near wells
one and five, and so those were the ones
that were implicated in the entire
sequence. And each one of these red dots
represents a a a smaller earthquake that
Young Soo was able to locate,
detect and locate.
And um so, it's it's perking along here.
We're now in
uh October 2010.
In February
2011,
what the um the sequence a a second
sequence actually started here
and ruptured back progressively over the
fault back towards these first two
disposal wells. So, this that second
sequence is not something that was seen
before, despite the fact that it was
studied by uh many investigators,
including us. And you'll notice there's
a big circle here. This was a
a a large event, a magnitude 4.7 event,
that led to the very expensive shut-in
of wells one and five.
Well two kept on pumping. It's not clear
that was the right decision, policy
decision. If you had had these this
catalog, you might have decided to shut
down well two and well five or perhaps
something different. Anyway, the point
is that this this sort of information
would have been extremely useful to have
in real time. And we could we could do
that then. We couldn't back in 2010, but
we can do that.
Other things uh another thing we found
out from this is that
is that once we get and sort of fill in
all the dots for for the earthquakes,
um we see a a very characteristic
pattern. So, this is a space-time plot.
This is now a still plot. This is
latitude on this axis and this is
calendar time from left to right. And
and each one of these dots, of course,
are seismicity within this this gray
population.
And and what you see are, if you look
closely, are these arc-shaped uh
structures
or parabolically shaped structures that
that occur over many scales from the
largest uh
scale to the these sort of small scales.
And this is the the sort of
characteristic signature of a diffusive
process.
And you know, there's there's fluids
being injected here. So, the natural
thing to assume is that it's it's the
propagation of fluids or perhaps fluid
pressure. The this diffusivities we get
are actually pretty high
for
for actual fluid flow unless it's
completely fracture controlled. Um this
is a zoom into some of those structures
and and as usually happens when you do
this, it doesn't look quite so
impressive when you zoom in.
But but this shows distance versus time
for one of these arc-shaped structures.
We fit a diffusivity to it. The numbers
we get are 10 to 100 m squared per
second. That's those are big numbers.
Um and so, whether it's fracture
controlled or it could be aseismic slip
that's diffusing,
regardless of what it is, uh if we had
this information in real time, it would
help us anticipate the evolution of the
sequence while it was underway and that
would be super useful for uh
for regulators.
So, YoungSoo has gone on to to study not
just 1 year, but 10 years of seismicity
for Oklahoma and Kansas where this has
been happening at a very large scale.
He he found over half a million events,
but again, only a subset of them were we
able to relocate accurately. That's
still 316,000 events.
Um the faults here are are close to
vertical, and so it's easier to
visualize them in map view than when the
faults have
have some dip to them or or cutting
through the crust at an angle.
So, we see some interesting uh things
here. So, this is the the
the Kansas-Oklahoma border. The
triangles represent stations, and each
one of those blue dots is a is an
earthquake.
This Nemaha Ridge here is thought to be
a barrier to fluid flow, and you can see
there's a a clear change in the behavior
across it. Not much going on over here,
very active over here, and the opposite
of that up here.
There are other features that appear
equally clear but have don't have such
an obvious uh
explanation, but we'd like to we'd like
to work with the geologists understand
why there's this geographically variable
uh responses uh
important.
And the the developments of catalogs of
here have have changed over time. The
original
USGS comprehensive catalog
had 11,517
events in it.
And uh the
uh Yang Xu's catalog has over a quarter
of a million over this This is over a
7-year time
period. So, that's a factor of 23 more
earthquakes than in the standard
catalog. Now,
part of that comes from having more
stations as these two studies do. So,
you're able to get more
stations. I think it's 13% more
stations. So, it's
it's helpful, but really almost all of
this uh improvement in the depth of the
catalog comes from applying machine
learning to the
uh to the seismic waveforms.
The cool thing about it is that it
allows you to,
uh, sort of
it allows structures that are only
hinted at by the the earlier catalogs to
really emerge very clearly. So, we can
see quite clearly that that there's
there are faults with with specific
orientations that are at at, uh, what
are called conjugate angles, and that
tells us something about the friction
that's active on these faults, and that
these faults are are optimally or close
to optimally
oriented.
Um, so from this, uh, decadal catalog,
uh,
Youngsoo has found that
that most magnitude four and larger
earthquakes, that is those earthquakes
that are large enough to cause damage,
occurred on structures that were
illuminated
by the by other smaller earthquakes
before the larger earthquakes
occurred. So, another way of putting
that is that, um,
12.
that,
uh,
Let's see. What's I'm trying to remember
the numbers here. Um, the
You can construct what's the equivalent
of a confusion matrix for for faults
illuminated by seismicity that either
did or did not host magnitude four
earthquakes, and, uh, what what he found
is that almost 90% of those events
occurred on structures that had been
could have been identified ahead of
time. On the other hand, only 4.4%
of those structures,
uh, that were big enough to have
earthquakes actually had earthquakes.
So, you you need to be mindful of both
of those numbers. Those probabilities
are small, but they're they're as large
in an absolute sense as those that, um,
the USGS uses for uh, potential
foreshocks on large strike-slip faults
in California. So, the the absolute
probabilities are low, but the
probability gains relative to the
background are quite high and and very
useful. So, again, if we had this in
real time, and we could do that now, um
it this would have been useful for
decision-making. I'll just zoom in on a
few of those sequences before
concluding. Here's the Woodward
sequence. Uh this box is about 20 km
across, so this is a a a big structure.
It's capable of having magnitude four or
or much larger earthquake they on it
based on its extent. And yet, all the
earthquakes were smaller than a
magnitude four. There were 89
earthquakes between magnitude three
and four. So, not all of these, in fact,
most of these larger structures don't
pose
large earthquakes, but but some of them
do. There's also some This is
color-coded by time. There's some
interesting down dip and eastward
migration with time uh that, you know,
we could try to relate to the injection
history of the wells around this region.
Here's a a large structure that did have
a large earthquake on it, a magnitude
5.1 earthquake. It has prolific
seismicity. It has these interesting
structures. This is what geologists call
a horse tail splay. And you can see
there's the suggestion, or maybe more
than a suggestion, of this of these
characteristic faulting angles called
conjugate uh
faulting. Here it's expressed even
better. This is in
in central Oklahoma. There's a clearly
preferred uh fault fabric. Should
emphasize that these faults are
unmapped. Uh almost all of them are
unmapped. We only know about them
because they they're illuminated by
seismicity.
Um
and here's uh the largest earthquake
that occurred there. It's a magnitude
5.8. Uh caused some damage. This the
Pawnee earthquake. It's actually the
largest earthquake in the instrumental
record for Oklahoma. And you can see
this this really beautiful, uh,
conjugate, uh, geometry.
Beautiful and complex, uh,
across, uh, different scales in this,
uh, in this in the
earthquakes involved in this sequence.
So, that's it for the what I'll show now
for the results. I'd like to emphasize
that that PhaseNet is uh, available on
and the the other methods once we
publish them are available on GitHub
being used widely nationally,
internationally, and for diverse
purposes,
uh, whether it's natural earthquakes,
induced earthquakes, uh, on the Earth or
or Mars.
And that there's a an emerging ecosystem
for AI on in seismology. We're
contributing to it, but, uh, it's being,
uh, the Italians have have contributed,
uh, a data set for AI. And there are,
um,
things like the SeisBench toolbox for
machine learning algorithms in, uh,
uh, seismology. The paper on that is,
uh, available on archive. I I think it
just got, uh, accepted for publication.
And, um, and there and there many, uh,
others. So, I, you know, I I'm I've
become a believer in this kind of open
science in the power of, uh,
uh,
this sort of, uh,
approach and collaboration. So, I hope
I've convinced you that that AI-based
earthquake monitoring is, uh, effective
and also worth emphasizing that it's
ready to go.
These deep catalogs I've been talking
about are are
available now and they're they're
becoming something of a commodity.
They're not so hard to generate anymore.
And they're they're going to make
seismologists' life complicated and
interesting. So, what we're used to are
earthquake catalogs that are sort of
static
uh in in time and they're sort of
one-size-fits-all and they're
authoritative. Um that landscape is
going to change. We're going to have
different catalogs for different
purposes. That's ultimately a good
thing, but the field's going to have to
uh
uh adapt to that.
And then the the next challenge is to
explore these deep catalogs, to develop
a deeper understanding of earthquake
processes. I've shown some pretty simple
examples of that. I think unsupervised
methods in uh
AI are are are probably ideally suited
for that uh that task and I look forward
to
uh using them uh
for that. So, with that I'll I'll stop
and
and take any questions that you might
have.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the
great talk, Rick. Um it was wonderful. I
I learned a lot more about
the earthquake. Yeah.
And one of your students uh name is very
close to mine.
Yes, that's right.
Yeah, so he doesn't have a U in it. He
just uh
Yeah, yeah, but the pronounce similar.
Yeah. Okay, if you have any questions,
please um um unmute yourself and ask or
you can
put that in the in the chat room.
Um
well,
the
the depth of the source locations is it
it can be also precisely detected uh
through through the flow.
Yeah, so so the depth is is
it can be determined. It's it's more
difficult because we we all we may all
our observations are on one side.
They're all at the surface. Yeah. So,
for things like latitude and longitude,
you can surround the earthquake and
constrain its location very
uh
closely. It's harder with depth because
the
the uh
you know, all the observations are from
the same in a sense from the surface in
the same direction.
Right. Yeah. Um but the um
Um so so it's probably
hard to know how precise
fully correct your your the depth
estimates from your algorithm. Clearly
you don't have the truth.
Yeah, I mean it is hard to be sure, but
as usual we you know when when we solve
these
you know the
earthquake location problem is is a big
estimation problem and it comes with a
covariance for what it's worth. It's a
it's a non-linear it's a linearized
problem typically. That's how we treat
it. And so we have some nominal error.
And and there you know there are
opportunities for testing how good that
error is. But but when we have similar
earthquake sources so nearby events we
can locate earthquakes to within
a meters of of one another horizontally
and tens of meters in depth.
Oh wow.
So that it it can be the that's
precision not accuracy. The it can be
super precise. Accuracy is a little
harder.
As you know.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Sounds good.
Okay. So all this you know the real time
the the
you know workflow you you guys have
developed um
with the abundant data
um
and I can see it's it would be really
helpful for the decision making um
whether
uh you know by predicting you know okay
so the earthquake is going to come um
somewhere um so
do something. Uh do do
um
Do do you have
enough data from California to tell the
residents in the California um you
Yeah, so so we're we're just we're
working on
the the data for Northern California.
So, you know, watch this space. We'll
have something within a year. Um at at
one of these deep catalogs for Northern
California. Um the examples I showed
were were for induced seismicity where
people were injecting fluids
um rather than naturally occurring
seismicity. Um there are places like the
geysers where people are injecting and
extracting fluid and inducing
earthquakes in the process
where this could be useful for
decision-making. But there are also
decisions to be made when natural
earthquakes are occurring, right? So,
USGS
you know, reports on
earthquake activity and it you know,
potential for larger earthquakes and
that that's, you know, their their
methods for
introducing time dependence to that
which could be interesting to pursue
with deep catalogs like this.
Okay. Sounds good. All right, and
there's a question
uh from Brian. He asked um oh, he said a
fantastic talk. Uh can you point me to
some papers or resources that describe
your
pre-processing steps? I'm working on a
different application in the frequency
domain and the noise
seems to pollute our predictions. So,
I'm curious on on tips that would help
our
Yeah, so I can't point you to it.
Well, I I so it's the
You you can find it with my name or or
Zhu, Z H U is the first author. It was
published in
IEEE something. I forget the name of the
journal. Uh but it's uh 2019. And if you
look at you look for deep denoiser, you
should find it. If if you have any
trouble at all finding it, if it takes
more than a minute,
please send me an email and I'd be happy
to to point you to it. Yeah. Oh, you can
look at my it's in it's on my Google
Scholar page.
It's uh
it has about 100 citations.
Nice. Nice. Okay.
All right. Is there any other questions?
Yes, I have a a question. Um well, I'm
um I'm wondering about the precursors of
earthquakes.
I I
I think there were some ideas that you
know, the tensions uh
uh
that uh
exist before an earthquake. So, they
manifest themselves in uh piezoelectric,
you know, effects. There's electric
field that can be detected on the
surface or maybe from satellite. And
is that uh something that can be used
indeed?
Well, you So, there there are claims to
that effect. And there's an AGU um
monograph on using electromagnetic
methods and
temperature and things like that to uh
uh to forecast earthquakes.
When people try to do that
prospectively, that is before the
earthquake happens, and they tend not to
work so well. It's it's retrospectively
that
they
um you know, claim to see anomalies. So,
I guess I To this point, I'm very
skeptical
that those the those anomalies are real.
If they were real, they are real, then
sure, methods like this could be used to
improve them, really. Uh uh
But um
Yeah. So, I mean, so so an any method
where you're anything that involves
signals, this would this sort of
approach
would be useful
for.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
Mhm.
Okay. Sounds good. Any other question?
Oh, the there is a question
from
Arkey. Great talk. Can you say something
about how AI can help us build better
earth models for wave propagation?
Yeah, so so that's a priority.
It's a great question. There there are
um
You know,
what what I've done is is sort of the
low-hanging fruit for AI and seismology.
That is to do these fairly simple tasks.
Um
AI can be used
for and and I think that's sort of would
be more in line with the usual sort of
talk you get here. So, AI can be used
for
uh
for approximating simulation. So, you
there are all sorts of way or
approximating uh
PDE solutions. So, the wave it could be
used for solving the wave equation.
It could be used uh
and even if it did so only
approximately, it would be enough to get
um
good uh good enough uh
sensitivity kernels to do uh it
inversions probably faster. Actually, if
if you uh
if you pose the problem
it turns out that you can you can
develop the adjoint um
you can develop basically adjoint uh
state methods using
um automatic differentiation and
which
takes advantage of the optimization
that's done for
uh
neural networks. That's that's sort of
done for you in in tensor flow, things
like that. So,
and there and there there methods for
dictionary type methods for doing um
sparse tomography that I I think are
also are related and and
highly relevant. So, there are all kinds
of ways
and
in addition to what I've, you know, just
said as as sprung to mind here where
um you could improve wave propagation
and you could improve
uh, information that's needed to do wave
propagation accurately uh, in the
in the earth.
All right, sounds good. Um, is there any
other questions?
Yeah, I have one question. So, for the
strategy of obtaining the models, you
have like one strategy is training a
series of models doing individual tasks
and then chain them together to get the
results. But then you have the another
strategy that to train them as a whole
whole like a problem set that to
optimize together. But also like in one
sense that this optimized together may
provide more constraints from these
different
uh, problems. But on the other hand is
that like maybe one of them will
dominant the training and then affect
the results. Can you say
a little bit more details comparing
these two strategies?
Yeah, so so that's a that's a good
question, Shinkai. And and it's you
know, as with a lot of things, if you
get the waiting wrong of of one versus
the other,
you'll get
it will be worse than if you did them,
say in this case, independently.
So, I I you know, what I was referring
to was that
that that sort of approach where you
consider them all together is
theoretically
optimum.
And and what we've come up with to this
point is
is competitive with other, you know,
with with doing it in a sort of serial
modular way. So, I I guess I'm pretty
confident in the long term, where long
term is 5 to 10 years, that a an
all-in-one kind of or end-to-end, if you
want to call it that, method
will be
superior. But it's an open question that
because I haven't proved it.
I can't. Is Is that Is that what you
were asking?
Yeah, thank you. Yeah, I think I think
like both these two strategies are very
interesting and like uh
Yeah, I think in like a in the long run
maybe one will show you like more
or better results. Yeah.
Yeah, looking forward to see that.
Yeah, and I I should also add that that
the the place to start is to
you know
it takes some effort to develop these
and to get people to use them, right?
So,
you know, doing it in a sort of modular
way helps get helps people get started.
Be harder if it were all at once, I
think.
Okay, sounds good. Any other questions?
Okay, well, I I found the um
the denoising paper of yours um
correct? It's a It's titled seismic
signal denoising and decomposition using
deep neural networks. 2019 IEEE. So, I
Okay.
So, Brian said, "Thanks." Okay.
Okay, that's great. Um
so,
well, let's thank our speaker today for
the great talk and great uh Q&A session.
Thank you so much for um accepting the
invitation and gave us the You gave us
the really talk uh Greg.
Thanks. That was very kind. And thanks
everybody.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
All right, bye-bye.
Okay, bye.